Good morning everyone.
As you can see from today's lecture title,
we're going to be talking about painting palaces and villas in the first
century,
a d.
But I could also call this lecture a lecture on a third and fourth style Roman
wall painting because we're going to continue our conversation today about the
four architectural styles of Roman wall painting.
In order to,
uh,
in order to do that,
I just want to remind you of what we talked about last time.
We covered the first and second styles of Roman wall painting and you'll
remember that what they had in common is that they both tried to create an
illusion of what they weren't.
In a sense,
think back to the first style of Roman wall painting when the painters tried to
transform a rubble wall into a marble wall to create the illusion that it was
indeed a marble wall rather than a rubble wall.
And in the case of the second style,
and I show you two examples again of that here,
the uh,
the from the villa,
the detail from the villa of Publius Scania's Sydney store on the left hand side
of the screen now in the Metropolitan Museum of art and the House of Augustus,
the room of the masks and the house of the,
of Augustus on the Palatine Hill in Rome.
Both examples of second style Roman wall painting.
And we saw in this instance that the illusion was to create the sense that you
were looking through a window to transform once again the rubble wall into a
window,
a window that showed what might lie outside the villa in the Paris style court.
For example,
remember this one with the shrine or throw loss that is surrounded by blue sky
and looks like it is located perhaps in a domestic peristyle.
And then over here,
uh,
this window that opens onto a sacro idyllic landscape,
we are being beckoned into that sacro idyllic landscape to explore the sacred
items within it.
And even beyond.
So opening up these walls illusionistic Lee both in the w to create an illusion
in both.
But in the case of the second style to open the wall up illusionistic Lee as a
panoramic window.
We also explored the fact that in the second style,
uh,
the Roman designers,
the Roman painters,
uh,
seem to have experimented with one point linear perspective.
This perspective in which all points recede to a single point in the distance.
And that we see that use of one point perspective.
In the second stall wall paintings in the room of the masks,
we also talked about the relationship between second style Roman wall painting
and theatrical architecture that they may have been looking at actual theaters
possibly and would possibly in a other more permanent materials that no longer
survive or they may have been creating this in part out of whole cloth.
Uh,
so this connection to the theater.
And the one last point that I want to remind you of is the fact that we also
discussed that although there's an enormous respect for earlier Greek
architecture,
not only in these paintings but in the temples and in the cities,
uh,
and in the sanctuaries that we've already explored and we see the Roman painters
using those elements of Greek architecture columns and pediments and the like in
the second style,
we also see that they are beginning to break the rules.
They have a respect for Greek architecture,
but they're all also willing to bend the rules.
An example being of course,
their use of the triangular pediment here,
but they have broken that triangular pediment apart to reveal the throw loss
here.
This is a very important development and we saw it already also in the sanctuary
of Fortuna premed Jania at Palestrina where you'll remember the column capitals
in the ramp and how they slanted those column capitals in a way that Greek
architects never would have done.
We see that same sort of breaking of the rules here.
It's extremely important because it shows again that although they revered the
past,
they were willing to look forward to the future and we're going to see,
especially in the late first century AED into the second century Aidy further
exploration of that kind of thing and it's going to have a huge impact on Roman
architecture.
In order to explore the third and fourth styles,
I need to go to a couple of other cities than the ones we've looked at thus far.
Uh,
I have the map here.
Once again that shows Campania we are going to be looking at the city of or a
villa in the town of a plunkitis which you see here.
We'll also be looking at an important villa at bus go,
Trey Causei and you can see the proximity of those two to the sites we've
already discussed.
Pompei,
Herculaneum,
Boscoreale Ali and also Naples.
Up here.
I want to look first at a villa or the paintings at a villa at a planted this
villa.
And you see,
a plan of adhere appears to have been belonged to a woman by the name of
[inaudible],
p o p p a e a p.
O p.
P.
E a who was pope paya.
Paul Pena was first the mistress,
and then the wife of Rome's notorious Emperor Nero.
Initially,
it looked as if the two were soulmates because she seemed to have as much as of
a mean streak as he did in that she encouraged him quite avidly to murder his
mother,
uh,
to murder his early,
his wife,
uh,
and even to murder the philosopher Seneca.
But despite the fact that they seem to have been soul mates,
uh,
neuro turned against her.
And in fact,
when she announced to him that she was pregnant,
he kicked her in the stomach,
uh,
which caused her death.
But after her death,
he took advantage of her death and divinized her made her a diva for his own
political purposes.
So a very interesting saga here,
uh,
between neuro and his wife pay up.
The reason that we think pope pay,
uh,
owned this villa or lived in this villa at some point and the villa dates we
believe to 20 to 10 BC.
The reason we believe that she lived there is that there was a,
uh,
a,
an Amphora,
one of these terracotta pots that was found in the excavation with the name of
the,
a Friedman Friedman of popup,
which suggests that she may well have lived there.
The other interesting observation that archeologists made when they excavated
this particular house is that it looked like it had been empty at the time of
the eruption of Vesuvius when it had been indeed covered over with ash and lava.
And they also found a lot of tools lying around the house,
which led to their belief,
uh,
that the house was probably in the process of being renovated.
It may have suffered damage in the earthquake and was in the process of being
renovated before reuse at the time Vesuvius struck.
If we look at this very good plan of what is preserved of this village today,
uh,
we can pick out a number of features that we've already become accustomed to in
our study of Roman domestic architecture houses and villas.
Uh,
we can see Paris dial courts with columns.
For example.
Uh,
we notice here the very large atrium with the,
uh,
[inaudible] designated here in plan.
There was a kitchen and an extensive kitchen over here as well.
We also see the use of columns,
these colonnades,
uh,
that,
that are part of Paris styles in some cases,
but also our colonnades that look out from the villa toward what,
what,
what surrounds it,
the landscape and the sea and so on that surround it.
And it's another example of what we began to see in the second phase of the plan
of the Ville of the mysteries in palm pay.
And that is an opening up of the facade,
a,
an incorporation of a larger number of windows,
uh,
to make the facade lighter and more airy,
as well as a series of colonnades with spectacular views toward what lay outside
the villa.
The most important room for us today,
uh,
is room number eight over here.
Uh,
and that room is part of an interior bath and elaborate interior bath.
that was part of visibility and room number eight,
which is basically a rectangular room as you can see here was the caldarium or
the warm room of that bath.
And it has some very interesting paintings that will show us the transition
between what we know of his second style Roman wall painting and what we term
third style Roman wall painting.
This is a view of the villa as it looks today.
You can see like Herculaneum,
it is very closely surrounded by a modern apartment houses and so on.
Here you see it,
it's only again,
part of what the original villa was.
But even from this view,
you can get a sense of how open it was compared to those very enclosed severe,
don't miss a tall Wicca houses that we began with a will you see,
hear this opening up views through columns,
both uh,
and doorways,
but also these peristyle courts and colonated courts and so on that again,
give this a very open,
oh,
open a appearance,
which is part of again,
this important development toward that kind of openness the house has in the
villa has in it both second and third style Roman wall paintings,
which again makes it extremely interesting because it is clear that there was
some transitioning here from one style to the other.
And I should mention by the way that with regard to the first,
second and third and fourth styles,
uh,
they weren't necessarily an evolution,
a development from one point to another.
By that I mean,
I don't think the painters of the patrons and necessarily had in mind,
we're going to start at point a and get to point d eventually.
I think that what we're dealing with here as we talk about this chronological,
uh,
evolution is a transition of styles that had something to do in part probably
with fashion,
with fashion for a particular way of decorating things and of course with
influences that were coming in from other parts of the world.
And in fact,
as far as the transition from the second to the third style,
uh,
this,
this cycle of style,
a style styles,
uh,
seems to suggest that at the time that the second style was at its most,
most,
uh,
popular,
was just when those who own these houses wanted to move on to something new.
Understandably once everybody had it,
it was time to think about something else.
And so the cycle just as these walls that we've been describing,
the room of the masks,
uh,
the funniest Sydney store and this one in a plant us that we see on the left
hand side of the screen,
just as they gained their greatest popularity,
there was a decision to move on to still another cycle of taste.
And again,
that's exactly what we're going to see at a plant as I show you here on the left
actually is not on your monument lists.
But in order to get us to the third style,
I want to say something about a second style painting.
It add a plant this and we see a detail of that.
The left hand side of the screen,
I compare it to the second style or a part of the second style wall,
uh,
of Pf Arnia Sydney store at Bosco Arreola.
And I think you can see the resemblance between the two.
The objectives are the same.
Uh,
the artist is trying to open up the wall to create a picture window through
which you can see,
uh,
a vista,
a vista that includes a round shrine just as we saw here.
So the same at a plant is around shrine in this case with the windows,
uh,
spread to see a cult statue inside.
And that shrine,
that circular Shriner throw loss surrounded by a peristyle,
the kind of Paris peristyle that one might have seen,
uh,
inside one of these Roman houses surrounding a garden.
Just as at bus Gloriola we see the,
the,
uh,
the gateway,
that seems to separate us from what lies beyond,
uh,
and we see again,
the structure surrounded by blue sky.
Uh,
we also see these very substantial columns that are characteristic of the second
style projecting out into the spectators space supporting and tablatures that
also project out into the spectators space and supporting also a lintel that has
a,
uh,
a ceiling,
with,
uh,
with coffers that recede into depth.
So what we see in second style at a plant is,
is very similar to what we saw at second style at Bosco Arreola and also at
Pompei Curriculum,
16 of the villa of the mysteries.
But if we look at call Darian eight room eight of the call Dorian of the bath,
we see something that may or may look superficially similar,
but it's actually very,
very different.
And I think you can pick out those differences very quickly.
Just as I can.
What we're looking at here is a view of a three walls and the most important
back wall here.
And then the walls to the right and to the left.
And if you look carefully,
you will see that the coloration is similar.
Uh,
the famous Pompei and read a nice maroons,
some blacks,
some gold,
uh,
use tier.
And again,
quick glance,
you see that there's a landscape of some sort with a blue sky right in the
center.
So you're being used to second style painting.
You might say to yourself,
oh,
well that's another window into something that lies beyond.
But if we look at it very carefully,
we will see that that is not the case at all.
We're going to see here that what has happened is that the artists have
rejected,
uh,
the perspect tival panoramas of the second style in favor of going back to a
appreciation of the flatness of a wall.
What is a wall?
But flat,
a wall is flat,
a flat wall is to be decorated.
So,
uh,
sort of,
believing in that integrity of that wall is the cornerstone of the thinking.
For what we call third style Roman wall painting.
And you can see the way the artist has treated the wall,
a series of zones,
uh,
painted Maroon zone or a Sokal down here,
a middle tier,
painted Pompei and read an upper tier,
painted this gold,
all of which looks like a series of stripes across the wall.
Let me show you another view,
which is a little bit brighter,
so that I think you can see this better.
The Maroon Zone,
the red zone,
and the gold zone.
Uh,
and if you look also at the,
uh,
the painting in the center,
you will see that there are some architectural elements,
but they are not the substantial architectural elements of the second style.
Uh,
they are very attenuated.
If you look at these,
and we'll,
I'll show you a detail in a moment.
It does.
They are in fact columns we'll see with capitals at the top,
but from a distance,
they don't look like they ha they don't look like columns.
They look like white stripes,
uh,
against a flat wall.
They support lintels.
As you can see here,
these lintels don't project,
they're just straight Lindell's.
It not broken in any way and they too are very delicate.
Uh,
and from a distance look like a stripe against the wall,
not like a lintel.
We can also see,
and I think that by having the detail will help you here.
Yeah.
Let me,
let me first show you a comparison between this wall and called Dorian eight and
the second style wall that we looked at just before.
And I think you can see very clearly the differences here,
the substantial columns in this case,
the opening up of the wall as a window to something that lies beyond this is
very different.
Yes,
there's a blue sky.
there's a tree,
but that scene is contained within a frame.
I think I can also illustrate that better here by showing you a detail of that
central panel.
That central panel by the way,
uh,
represents not something that one would be likely to see outside the window of
one's house.
Uh,
but rather a mythological scene,
uh,
which represents the legendary hero Hercules.
You see him over here,
uh,
Hercules and in fact,
Hercules has just finished the last of his 12 labors.
Uh,
and he has brought back the apples of the disparities which you see sitting on a
rock over here.
Uh,
and so he is celebrating the last of the,
uh,
of,
of these 12 labors.
For some reason he seems to be the kind of tree hugger here.
He seems to be hugging the tree.
A tree that has a yellow ribbon tied around it.
We,
we use today yellow,
really Thai yellow ribbons around things are a variety of reasons as we know,
we don't know exactly why the Romans did that,
but we see that frequently in Roman wall painting.
But here he is standing at the base of the tree is Labor's completed.
Uh,
and tree again is surrounded by blue sky.
But I think you can see that it is not a window into something that lies beyond
because the scene is contained within this frame.
And what the artist has done is outlawed the frame with a very black dark black
outline.
Now,
whether this has anything to do with us,
old curtains that we talked about in the second style might be interesting to
speculate,
but it looks to us like it's basically just a frame that is making it clear that
this is flat,
that what we are dealing here with,
what we are dealing with here is a flat wall onto which a panel picture has been
attached.
It is Haung.
It seems to be hung on that flat wall.
It is not meant as a,
as a window or a panorama into something else besides the black frame.
You see there's also a moulded frame very nicely painted here and in this detail
you can see that again,
what looked like stripes and white stripes on a flat wall from a distance are
indeed columns.
You can see that they support capitols and a lintel up above,
but from a distance,
again,
they don't look that way and their capitals that are,
they are columns and capital's very different from what we've seen before
because again,
they are very,
very,
very attenuated,
very deaf,
very delicate.
Uh,
they don't have any of the substance of the columns of the second style.
Look up above the panel picture of Hercules.
And you'll see,
and I have a better detail of this in a moment,
a series of figures that are located in the yellow zone and I can show them
better to you perhaps here where you're looking also at a view of the Sokal.
This side of the wall,
you may have noticed this and the general view is actually a niche is actually a
niche.
A rectangular is fairly shallow,
rectangular niche there.
So the painting continues into that niche,
which gives it a little sense of depth,
a little more sense of depth than it would have otherwise.
Uh,
and uh,
above,
above the niche is a soffit,
which you can see is also painted.
And I show you a detail of that soffit up above.
If you look at what's right above the picture,
the painting of Hercules,
you will see,
and I'll show you these in detail in a moment.
A forest that is a man who plays a Sithrah,
uh,
who was seated there and his playing his instrument on either side of him.
Uh,
we see panel pictures and then on top of those panel pictures,
peacocks,
peacocks that are represented frontally and look out toward us.
And if you look at both,
and we'll look at them in detail again momentarily.
If you look at the Sephoras and if you look at the peacocks,
you see that they are standing on ground lines,
but ground lines that don't look like they have any depth.
In fact,
they're standing somewhere where you couldn't really stand.
Uh,
which is one of the interesting features of third style.
Again,
this desire to move and to respect the flatness of the wall.
If we look at the Sop,
uh,
we see that that too is painted in red and gold,
that it is divided into a series of panels that in those panels we see floating
mythological figures,
a woman on a bull.
I'll show you a detail of her in a moment,
just floating in the center that she doesn't seem to be in any space at all.
She's just floating there.
And then on either side,
a niche with a shell at the top with standing figures.
And then strangely enough,
pictures of still life paintings.
Uh,
right below those.
Here's here are all of those details here we see the SIF tourist,
uh,
sitting again where there doesn't seem to be,
he,
there is a,
uh,
a brown,
a Maroon or brown line here,
but it doesn't look like it occupies any space.
So there's this interesting tension between the flatness of the wall and the
fact that there's a figure that seems to be sitting somewhere where there's no
place to sit.
A the same with the peacocks.
You can see them.
This one standing on this white flat line,
uh,
his toes do seem to be a,
you know,
projecting a bit over those.
So this is interesting tension between what's flat and what might be,
might,
might have a hint of space.
And then below that,
one of these sacro idyllic landscapes,
again,
framed in black,
making it clear that we are,
we are to read this as a panel picture hanging on a flat wall,
a kind of picture gallery,
uh,
in a way that's very different from second style up here.
Uh,
a mysterious figure with a sacrificial dish,
a standing Billy [inaudible] in a niche with a shell decoration at the top,
and then it's still life painting with fruit,
uh,
down below.
And then up here,
something that we're going to see becomes ubiquitous in third style Roman wall
painting,
a figure that floats in the center of a colored panel,
either red or black or white.
In this case,
a,
uh,
mostly nude female figure who is riding.
As you can see on the back of a bull,
uh,
at least the front of the,
of the animal is a bowl.
And you can see the back of the animal has a,
has a fish tail.
So it's a kind of a bull like sea creature as you can see here.
So this room,
this very important room called Dorian eight in the villa.
At a plant as seems to be a good example of this transition from second style,
which was also in the house to some new cycle of,
uh,
of fashion in Roman painting.
And example of the mature third style,
uh,
can be seen in two rooms,
the red room and the black room,
so called for obvious reasons.
This is the red room,
uh,
that belong to the villa of a grip of posthumous at bus go.
Trey Causei that dates to around 11 BC.
We believe this house we think,
uh,
also had imperial connections.
That is,
we think that this house was put up in honor of the first emperor of Rome.
Augustus is only child.
His daughter Julia,
the marriage of Julia to Tiberius t.
I.
B,
e R.
I,
u s the man who was to become the second emperor of Rome.
The marriage of Julia to tie Bearius may have been the occasion for the
decoration of this house.
It bears the name of one of Julia's sons by a different man,
by Marcus Agrippa.
Uh,
her son,
her last son,
his name was a grip,
a posthumous,
because he was born after she was impregnated obviously by a group of before he
died.
But the child was actually born after the death of a grip,
a hence his name,
a grip of posthumous.
Uh,
there's some speculation that he may have lived in this villa at some point,
but what's important to us is the likelihood seems to be that just as with the
villa at a plumpness,
this villa seems to have been owned by someone in the imperial family,
which is very important because it suggests to us,
uh,
not only that the finest artists of the day must have been working on these as
they did in Rome for the house of Augustus or in Prima Porta for the villa of
Libya.
But also leads me at least to speculate that it's possible that these
interesting transitions from third,
from second to third style and third style to fourth style may have come at the
behest of the artists who were these very high level artists who were working,
uh,
in the imperial employee.
It makes a certain amount of sense to speculate that that might've been the
case.
So here we have the red room of the villa of a grip of posthumous at Bosco Trey
Cozzie and we can see some of the same features that we saw in called RM eight
of the villa at a plant.
As we see once again that those substantial columns at that opening in the wall
is gone forever.
Banished.
In fact,
the Romans never returned,
uh,
to their quest after one point perspective.
For example,
respect for the integrity of the wall,
the flatness of the wall,
the wall as a surface to be decorated.
Uh,
we see that they have decorated it with a system of tears,
a black,
uh,
Sokal at the bottom,
than a red central zone and a red upper zone.
And by the way,
we can still see some,
some,
we still get some sense that they have looked at earlier,
second style wall paintings.
Because if you look at the structure,
the overall structure of this wall,
for example,
there still seems to be a central panel flanked by wings.
This whole idea of Reggie and us be Tahlia that we talked about that goes back
to theater design.
Uh,
there's,
there's certainly a hint of that still here in the general arrangement or
formatting of the wall,
but it is completely flat black zone,
red zone.
And then,
although we will see in detail that we have a column here with a capital at the
top from a distance,
again,
it looks like a white stripe on a flat wall and that's deliberate on the part of
the artists.
Again,
here there's a panel in the center,
but it is not a panel that serves as a window to what lies beyond.
It is a panel that is meant to be just that a panel.
Uh,
it's meant to imitate perhaps a marble painted panel that would have actually
hung on a wall in a house or villa like this,
but depicting that here in paint.
So it is meant to be,
we are meant to see it as a panel picture that hangs on a flat wall in the red
room at Bosco.
Trey Causei.
Uh,
we can see also some vegetal decoration.
Very,
very delicate.
Doesn't occupy space at all,
decorates the flat wall above.
So very similar to what we saw.
Again in called Dorian made.
Here's a detail of the red room where we can see the sacro idyllic landscape
better.
You can see that it follows in the line of others sacro idyllic landscapes that
we've seen.
It has a shrine in this case,
a column that supports an urn at the top with the tree behind that,
uh,
some sort of wall with windows over here.
And in this case,
uh,
a group of shepherds with their flocks,
and other possibly figures,
possibly involved in some kind of ritual,
uh,
located,
in and around,
uh,
the shrine.
Or you can also see here extremely well in detail the way in which they have
outlined this panel with a black frame to make it very clear that this is
contained within a frame that beyond that they have.
You can now see that this is a column,
a very attenuated,
very delicate column,
more a Collinet,
we might call it a with a capital at the top,
but it is meant here not to,
to uh,
to occupy any real space,
not to project into the viewers space,
but to serve as a second frame for the panel picture that is placed on the flat
wall.
I think it's instructive to compare this to what we saw in the room of the masks
house of Augustus,
Palatine Hill,
mature second style,
so mature,
second style commissioned by an imperial patron,
mature third style commissioned by we think an imperial patron.
Uh,
both sacro idyllic landscapes with white backgrounds.
But you can see the main difference here,
not only the substantial architecture,
but the fact that the white background continues behind the architecture,
right?
It continues behind the architecture here,
here,
which gives us the sense again,
that this is something that's a misty landscape of some sort that one could at
least with one's eye,
but also perhaps oneself could actually enter into and wander around.
That's the sense you get here.
But here you are.
You are stopped from doing that.
There's nothing more here than a panel picture that hangs on a wall.
Now you might say to me that if we're going back to respecting the wall and,
and,
and to,
uh,
having a painting that is fairly flat,
that,
oh,
you know,
what are we going back to the first stop of Roman wall painting.
And I remind you of one of the first Dell Roman wall paintings that we looked at
together,
but it really is very different from the first style as well because in the
first dial you'll remember the wall was not actually flat.
The wall was built up as a relief,
uh,
in a series of architectural zones.
Uh,
and then though the individual blocks were painted different colors to give an
illusion once again that this was not a,
a plain wall,
but rather a very exotic and expensive marble wall with marbles brought from all
over the world,
uh,
to decorate it.
So an illusion of something that it wasn't here in the third style.
Uh,
we are again not dealing with any illusions really at all,
but just a respect for the flatness of the wall,
decorating that flat wall with a kind of wallpaper through paint.
Uh,
and then putting on that flat wallpapered wall pictures hanging pictures just as
we hang pictures on flat walls today,
the Avila at Bosco Trey Causei also has a black room,
a so called because the main color there,
the main background color there is as you can see black it too is interesting,
uh,
and has a and interesting in a somewhat different way but is a quintessential
example of mature third style Roman architectural painting.
We see once again that the room has been divided into a central center,
a central area with wings,
one on either side.
We also see that it has been divided into painted zones,
red at the bottom,
black in the center,
black.
Also at the top we can see that there are architectural members,
although again,
they look from a distance,
like white stripes on a black wall.
But if we get up close to them and I'll show you even some,
some closer views in a moment,
we will see that we are dealing with very,
very,
very attenuated Colinette's with capitals at the top.
And notice,
and this has been true throughout,
they decorate these columns also all up and down,
uh,
all along the way with floral motifs and so on and so forth,
which also underscores,
uh,
their function as a decorative motif rather than an actual column.
The column supports the Collinet support.
You know,
what looks like a,
a very,
um,
simple pediment.
Uh,
it just,
it just slightly peaked as you can see up there.
Uh,
and uh,
but,
but there is one,
this painting is interesting because if you look carefully at the freeze at the
upper,
most part of the columns are Colinette's.
You will see that there is some hint of space there.
Look at the way it undulates.
There's,
uh,
it,
it recedes over here,
receives over there and then it also meanders a in the center.
So there's a slight hint in this particular case of some space,
some respect session into depth,
which only adds to the intrigue and mystery of these incredible paintings.
These are very,
very interesting in detail.
I can show you here,
for example,
uh,
the swans,
we see some swans and remember these swans,
this again seems to be an imperial house because we will see swans are very
important for the emperor Augustus.
And he decorates the RF pacas enrollment,
great work of architecture and sculpture with swans that may make reference to a
new golden age that he is ushered in.
We see those here,
but look at them.
Look at the way they rest on these little,
a candelabra like a torches.
And then those in turn on a spiraling a canvas,
a tendril that doesn't look like it could support anything at all.
How very strange,
I mean,
to have a swan supported by a tendril like this,
this sort of thing couldn't actually work.
Uh,
and it's one of,
again,
the intrigues of the details of painting such as these.
This is another interesting detail because it shows again a kind of candelabra.
I'm supporting a panel picture that we are meant to read as a panel picture on
the wall.
And if you look carefully,
you can see the Egyptian Ising motifs.
Uh,
in that panel picture,
uh,
there was,
a,
an extreme Egypt,
Romania that spread through Rome and Italy after a Augustus was victorious over
Mark Antony and Cleopatra at the famous battle of Actium a Augustus initially
use these egyptianize and motifs to make political,
uh,
remarks about his,
his,
uh,
his victory over Cleopatra and Antony.
But over time it became more a fashion,
uh,
and we begin to see Egyptian Ising motifs not only in the homes of members of
the imperial family,
but even used even more widely than that.
Another detail,
a shows again,
that central area with the,
now you can see that they are indeed Colinette's with capitals at the top.
You can also see there are a couple of medallions that turned out to be
medallions that have heads in them over here.
But here you can see how fanciful it gets,
even though this is clearly a colinette with a capital a what,
what capital supports then I mean,
an unusual building practice supports on top of it,
a medallion with a head,
and then another curlicue on top of that.
And that supports the pediment and that has on the edge,
this very decorative dripping off the side.
I mean,
there's no,
this is fantastic in that regard.
Fantastic.
And an end.
And,
and they're,
they're clearly having fun,
uh,
with these,
details and with using these wonderful details is drop element over here.
For example,
the portraits are intro,
the images are interested in.
Your heads are interesting.
Many scholars that believe that their representations of God's like Apollo,
uh,
but a couple of scholars have put forward the idea and I find it a very
attractive one that we may actually have there.
Two of them.
We may actually have a portrait of Julia,
uh,
whose marriage may have been commemorated here and have her,
of her stepmother,
uh,
Livia.
The emperors of Rome during the age of Augustus,
most interesting of all is the small sacro idyllic landscape that floats in the
center of the panel.
Again,
in third style Roman wall painting,
we either tend to have painted panels in the center with frames as we've seen
thus far or floating elements in the center.
They could be a floating woman on the back of a,
of a bull slash sea creature,
or they can be a sacro idyllic landscape as we see here.
And here's another detail where we can blow up that sacro idyllic landscape and
see again that it is just the sort of a sacred and idyllic landscape we've seen
before with the shrine,
top of a column,
a,
a building over here,
trees,
a tree in the center of their trees,
and then various sacrificial goings on in front of that.
But from a distance,
again,
it just looks like some sort of object floating in the center of a very large
black flat wall.
One decorative motif among many.
We looked last time at the,
uh,
magnificent paintings in the villa of Livia at Prima Porta.
And we talked about the fact that that was the quintessential second style wall
because more than any other we saw it was truly the wall as Panorama as a vista
into something that might lie beyond.
And we described in great detail,
uh,
the features of this particular painting.
It's interesting that you wouldn't think that a garden escape would be a good
subject for third style Roman wall painting,
a kind of painting that again,
uh,
respects the flatness of a wall.
And yet we do have examples of what we would term a third style Roman wall
painting showing the depiction of a garden scape.
And I turned to that.
Now the painting that you look at is on the wall of the house of the orchard.
The causes dealt through Taito in Pompei,
uh,
in the orchard,
the so called orchard cubic ulum and it dates to add 25 to a d 50,
so considerably later.
And it's interesting,
by the way,
to note the chronology here.
Third Style Roman wall painting has a quite long life because if we talk about
it being used already in 20 to 10 BC at a plant is,
and we're now looking at a house,
it could be as late as 50,
might've been decorated as late as 50.
And uh,
that takes us,
you know,
60,
70,
or 70 years for this one style.
So although I said these are cycles of fashion,
fashion wasn't changing all that quickly at this particular juncture.
But here we see a garden scape,
uh,
in what we would call a third style wall.
Now why do we call this a third style wall?
Uh,
it's divided into zones.
We have a black Sokal down here.
We have a zone here,
which seems to show a fence,
a more substantial fence than we saw in the villa,
the garden's scape of Libya.
Uh,
it does seem to support some,
a marble vessels or vases here.
So you might,
you know,
you look at the bottom,
you think,
well,
maybe there is some suggestion of some space.
In fact,
if you look very carefully at the Gateway of the fence,
you can see that there is some attempt to represent it as if it receives into
depth,
at least the doorway.
So there's some attempted that here.
But if you look at this zone,
I think you'll agree with me that the artists have,
once again,
the painters of once again respected the flatness of the wall.
Yes,
there are columns here,
but they are not substantial columns.
They are attenuated columns,
maybe not as attenuated as Bosco Trey Causei,
but attenuated.
Nonetheless,
they do have capitals at the top.
But as you walk into this room and look at them from a distance,
they look like gold stripes on a flat back wall.
And in fact,
the fact that the wall was painted black is very significant and not blue as we
saw in the garden scape of Livia,
uh,
at Prima Porta.
And look also what's particularly interesting is the way in which the artist has
positioned the trees,
uh,
within the frames of the columns.
If you look very closely,
you will see that there isn't a single leaf that either overlaps the columns or
the disappears behind the columns.
They are completely contained within those columns.
They are represented very abstractly,
very flat.
Uh,
and so because they are contained within those,
we get the impression,
not that we're looking at a garden scape that is somehow viewed through a window
behind the columns,
but is it,
it's almost as if we're looking at a Japanese screen or something like that.
It,
it's uh,
it's a flat surface that has been decorated with depictions of trees,
not a view to look at trees that lie behind these columns.
It's,
it's very,
it's really fascinatingly done I think.
And if we look at a detail of the wall in the Casa del Fruit Taito over here and
have a tree and a detail of a tree from Olivia's villa at Prima Porta,
I think we again see the differences between the two blue background,
which gives us a sense of reality here.
Mountains in the background.
As you'll remember,
a black background to your gives a very different effect here.
We talked about how the artist was a particularly good observer of nature,
had really gone out and looked at real trees,
uh,
had looked at the way in which leaves rustled and the breeze had looked at the
way in which again,
light falls differently on a leaves.
You could,
it can bei them in light or it conveyed them in shadow.
And we looked at the very realistic way in which the artist depicted the birds
who are in flight and then a light on a,
uh,
on a leaf or a branch of the tree.
Look at the difference here.
Uh,
the leaves are beautifully rendered,
beautifully rendered,
but they are rendered,
they are all rendered essentially the same.
You don't have the same sense of the difference of light and shadow.
You don't have the same sense.
I mean,
you don't,
these seem immutable,
not as if they could be ruffled by the breeze at all immutable shapes.
And look at the difference in the bird who himself or herself,
uh,
seems to be a shape against a black background.
You don't get the sense,
there's no sense of movement as you see of the birds.
As you see at the villa of Livia at Prima Porta,
the bird is one shape among many shapes.
The snake has the sinuous snake that makes its way up.
The tree.
Uh,
has,
uh,
you know,
you have some sense again of this as a teasing us here,
there's some sense of depth because as it's slithers all along here,
you get the sense that it is intertwining itself,
uh,
with,
with the trunk of the tree.
So that may be,
there's a hint of,
have some depth and some motion there.
So this is interesting play I think that the artist has,
has,
uh,
created here.
But on the whole,
um,
this again is a painting that clearly respects all the tenants that have come to
be from the point of view of these artists.
Third Style Roman wall painting.
Even for a subject as a,
as unlikely for this as a garden scape.
We have talked about third cell Roman wall painting in Campania.
We have talked about the fact that a lot of it seems to be connected in some way
to members of the imperial household.
Uh,
and we see the same also in Rome and it's to Rome that I would now like to turn
and specifically to the Golden House or the Dome was our area of the Emperor
Nero.
I show you a view of the famous octagonal room of neuros Domus area.
It is one of the greatest rooms enrollment architecture.
It's an octagonal room that has a large oculus.
It is made out of concrete.
It has radiating alcoves,
uh,
and it is in a sense of grandiose version of the figure Doriam,
that we saw in the style being informed Bas at palm pay.
It is part of a very major architectural revolution under Nero.
It is extremely important.
We'll talk about it in great detail,
visa vi the architecture in a later lecture.
But I do want to bring up just the contextually,
it works better for me to talk about the painting separately and the paintings
in connection to paintings and Pompei and it's to those paintings that I'm going
to turn.
Now the paintings in Nero's Domus area that we will see are both third and also
fourth style Roman painting.
So once again,
we seem to be in a situation where we are looking at a palace in this case
commissioned by an imperial patron in which it looks like there was an important
transition from one Roman decoration,
one Roman wall painting,
decoration style,
uh,
to a another in this case.
The third style to the fourth style.
The dome is salary of paintings are important,
uh,
for three major reasons.
The first reason is we can date them exactly.
We know that these paintings,
both of the third and the fourth styles were done in the Domus area between 64
and 68 a d we also know,
and we know this very rarely,
the name of the painter who was responsible for the third and fourth style
paintings in the Domus area.
His name is one.
You will,
I hope you will.
I hope.
I know you will never forget,
uh,
because his name was fabulous.
Fab,
U,
l l,
U s fabulous,
and he was indeed as you shall see,
truly fabulous,
fabulous,
uh,
is known from,
we know him from the writings of Pliny Plin.
Why many of you probably read the writings of Plenty,
tells us a lot about art.
Ancient Art and plenty tells us that a fabulous was the painter or the Dome Miss
Aria in Rome.
And he tells us a couple of other interesting tidbits about fabulous.
He tells us that fabulous.
Always used to paint in a toga.
Now painting in a Toga is like painting in a three piece suit today you wouldn't
paint in the toe,
you know,
painting and a Toga makes no sense to paint in a Toga,
but he obviously,
whether he really painted into Toka,
we don't know.
Uh,
but that was his reputation,
which means he dressed up for the event,
took it very seriously.
We also know from plenty that are plenty.
Tells us that the dome is our area,
was fabulous,
is prison.
Why was it fabulous?
Is Prison.
It was fabulous.
Is Prison because any of you who have visited the dome is salary.
And those of you who haven't,
I hope you will when you're enrolling because it's extraordinary place to see.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll see that it is Carter after Carter,
after Carter,
and we only have today a very small piece of the Domus area preserved.
Uh,
so if,
if,
if a fabulous,
his job was to paint all of the walls and all of the ceilings of the Domus area,
it would have indeed taken a lifetime.
It would have indeed,
uh,
served as a kind of prison for him.
I suppose a later,
um,
might be interesting to think of him in connection to.
He was not as great as,
but,
uh,
he was in a sense the Michelangelo of his time,
think about Michelangelo and the Sistine ceiling and all the time that he
devoted to,
uh,
to painting,
that extraordinary space also in Rome.
I show you a couple of views of the carters.
I'm not going to go into detail now on exactly why this is the case,
but the dome is,
our area is now underground.
It's subterranean.
It was,
it was,
uh,
raised to the ground and covered over in part by a later Roman emperor that
we'll talk about in the future.
So if you wouldn't,
you visited today,
you need to go underground.
It was buried for a long time and rediscovered in the renaissance.
And it's interesting because we know that the famous painter,
Raphael,
the famous renaissance painter,
went underground and was one of the first to see,
uh,
the paintings of the Dome is salary because Rafael left a graffito on the wall,
which basically says Raphael was here.
Uh,
and we're fortunate that he left that because it tells us again that he was
here.
And we're not surprised because this is a low Jetta in the Vatican today that
was designed by when it was painted by raw fail.
And you can see how much the paintings of the Dome is our more weathered,
obviously,
than the one on the left.
But the paintings of the Dome is salary.
I had a huge impact on Rafael.
I'm going to show you three rooms and the Domus area.
The first is the,
and I'm sorry I have to show you this too.
In black and white.
It's the only and it's very hard to photograph there and it's uh,
one of the,
it's the only image I happen to have of this wall,
but I am showing you a room called the Sala daily.
Ooh.
Celente,
which means the room of the birds and like the other paintings I'm going to show
you today,
a dates to 64 to 68 a d.
You can see that this is a third style Roman wall painting.
Uh,
it partakes of all the features that we've already described for third style
Roman wall painting.
It,
it,
uh,
um,
has a flat wall as you can see here.
It's not painted red or black,
but in this case white,
which makes it even more delicate looking.
But it is definitely,
they have,
uh,
definitely,
um,
observe the integrity of the wall and painted it white.
Uh,
you can also see that the architectural members that there are,
are very attenuated and look like stripes on the wall from a distance.
You can see that some of the frames are vegetal or floral,
very delicate as you can see here.
And then in the central panels.
And it's the reason that it's called the solid daily Buccellati.
We have little birds on those little birds float,
uh,
in the center of these panels.
Once again,
a decorative motif among many,
uh,
so the flatness of the wall observed a wall that is flat and to be decorated by
the painter.
That's the solid daily [inaudible] selectee third style.
Uh,
this is a vault in the,
uh,
Domus area,
which is useful for us because here we can get a better sense of the color.
Once again,
uh,
the background is white,
and once again,
the integrity of the wall has been respected.
The artist has divided that wall into a series of panels.
But within those panels we see once again a sea creatures in this case,
floating in the center of those framed panels.
We are meant to read them as frame panels.
Not as views into some other world.
A note also that some of the frames are done with vegetal and floral floral
motifs.
Very,
very delicate,
very attractive,
very ephemeral in a sense,
very light light weight against that white background,
so very much.
Again,
another example of a third style Roman wall painting,
but then there is this room and this room,
his room 78 and [inaudible] 78 uh,
is extremely important for us because we see something else is happening in room
78 yes,
it does still have a white wall.
Yes,
it does still use a floral decoration for some of the frames.
it does have a framed panels in this case,
not with black but with a red frames as you can see here,
all elements of the third style.
Absolutely.
So it partakes of a number of third style elements.
The White Wall itself is very third style thing to do.
But you will notice of course that something new has happened here and that is
more substantial architecture has been or the representation of more substantial
architecture has been reintroduced a,
if you look at these architectural elements that frame some of the panels,
you will see that we see once again real columns,
real columns that seem to support projecting lintels.
Uh,
and then through those,
once again a white background in this case,
but through those we see other elements of architecture here at two storied
columnar,
uh,
monument and overhear what seems to be a broken triangular pediment supported by
columns.
So architecture is substantial.
Architecture is reintroduced in the central zone flanking the panels on either
side,
but it is a different architecture than we've ever seen before because we never
see a complete building.
We see only fragments of buildings this broken triangular pediment on its own.
As an example of that.
Fragments of buildings which we will see are depicted in what I would describe
as illogical space.
They don't look like they're actually occupying space the way a regular building
wood or wood or,
or what and what is characteristic of the second style but depicted fragments of
buildings depicted in illogical space.
And then very important than the upper most zone.
We see a depiction of a number of these fragments of architecture all jumbled
together almost to create a building.
Although it isn't a building that actually works.
I like to call these architectural cages because there they are individual
elements,
individual fragments again,
that are grouped together,
architectural cages that often have in them very strange,
uh,
mythological and other creatures,
most of whom are very difficult to identify today.
So we see this incredible transition between the third style Roman wall painting
that fabulous is using for the Domus area to something that is transitioning us
into what we call the fourth style.
In fact,
I would call this room a fourth style,
a Roman Room,
a fourth style painted room.
And the genius behind this I would speculate,
uh,
was a fabulous himself.
I want to show you another example of,
of fourth style because we believe fourth style.
Remember the date of the Dome is salary is 64 to 68.
Uh,
so if it is being is coming to the fore,
the fourth style at that time,
it means that it is about the time of the earthquake in palm pay.
And we do see paintings in palm pay that we believe date between the earthquake
of 62 and the eruption of Vesuvius of 79 that are examples.
Also a fourth style Roman wall painting.
This is one of them.
It's a wall from the house of the vestals in Pompei at dates to 62 to 78 and we
can see exactly what I was describing at the dome is our area.
We look at the bottom part and we see that it still has a,
it still looks like a third style wall in that we see golden panels and red
panels with floating figures in the center and with a floral decorations around
those we see over here and mythological panel with a black frame around it.
Uh,
that is meant to look like a panel picture hanging on a flat wall.
All of that is exactly what we saw in the third style.
But again,
what separates this from a third style painting is this reintroduction of
architecture over here,
architecture PR presented against a white background,
but it's not a full building.
It is a fragment of a building,
a fragment of a building with substantial architectural members and of
projecting and tablature above.
And then in the upper zone,
again against a white background,
those architectural cages,
those fragments of architecture that had been jumbled together and are used as a
Amelia for these very strange creatures,
animal,
human and the like,
uh,
that are,
that are located in them,
these architectural cages that are also decorated with a strange and interesting
ornamentation,
uh,
at the upper most parts.
So another example of fourth style,
our very best examples of fourth style Roman wall painting all come from a
single house in palm pay.
It is a house that we looked at together before it is the house of the Betty.
Uh,
you'll remember the kitchen in the house of the [inaudible],
for example,
the wonderful garden,
uh,
that we explored there.
Uh,
it is also a house that has,
um,
an incredible array of paintings and it shows us several stages of the fourth
style.
And I should mention also that while we call these styles first,
second,
third,
and fourth as anything else,
they have sub style,
sub sub styles,
uh,
and transition periods.
You know,
one can refer too late for early second style and mature second style late
second style,
early third style transit.
You know,
all of there are certain subtleties because again,
remember the artists who were making these were not thinking,
oh,
I'm transitioning from the second to the third style.
They were just moving on.
They were experimenting with things they hadn't experimented before and they
soon found themselves in a different mill.
Yup.
So there are those subtleties and we can see those in the house of the Betty.
I can show you early,
middle and even late,
uh,
fourth style at the house of the [inaudible],
which is just what I'm going to do.
Now.
We're going to begin with garden room Q,
which is the one that you see here,
which you can see from the monument list.
We believe dates to 62 to 70 Aidy garden room queue.
Now,
if all of garden room cue that was preserved was the bottom part,
if you didn't have that very top zone,
and I asked you what style is this,
you would probably tell me third style and you'd be right that it was third
style.
But the addition of that zone in the upper most part gives it away as a fourth
stall wall.
But it's again,
a very good example of an early one because we can see this transition.
So in the bottom,
again,
very much adhering to the tenants of third style Roman wall painting design,
respecting the flatness,
the wall,
dividing the wall into a series of zones.
Uh,
a Sokal that's black,
uh,
a main section that's red,
a sort of wings on either side that are also black.
But as you look at this wall from a distance,
those black elements look like stripes,
large black stripes on the wall.
And even within those black stripes,
we see these very attenuated,
delicate colinette's close up.
You can see that they're calling nets,
but from a distance,
again,
they look like gold stripes on a flat wall,
floating,
Floating,
um,
uh,
mythological figures in the center as is characteristic of the first doll.
And then there was a panel painting over here that was rudely removed by
treasure hunters at one point.
So,
uh,
panel pictures as well as floating a mythological figures.
And then at the upper most part you see this does this addition white ground
architectural,
um,
cages as I've described them with a whole panoply of interesting mythological
and other figures that are inserted into those architectural cages.
So a very early example of fourth style Roman wall painting in the house of the
Betty in Rome.
These,
again are so interesting in detail.
If you blow this up to the size that we see it here,
you will see that this is that black background in between the red panels that
we were looking at before.
You can see all kinds of strange things going on here in detail.
A female figure semi naked.
Uh,
she's clashing her symbol,
she's dancing here,
uh,
and she is supporting on her head.
She's oblivious to the fact that she's supporting on her head.
The base of one of these,
one of these colinette's as you can see here,
pays no heed whatsoever that she's serving as a support for the colonnades and
that either side of her,
uh,
what we call herms,
h e r m s,
uh,
which are part human and part pedestal,
male heads,
bearded male heads carrying libation dishes or whatever on either side.
And then a very interesting sacrificing down here.
So again,
as I've said so many times looking at these paintings,
the details of these paintings is a very intriguing experience.
Uh,
the room that seems to be a good example of the mid,
uh,
fourth s style is the house of the vets.
He a room of Pentheus,
which we date to around 70 a d.
You see it here,
it is very well preserved.
Uh,
it is a room in which the color gold abounds.
As you can see,
a Maroon,
a circle,
the gold central zone,
uh,
it partakes of third style in that you can see that the main parts of the wall
are flat with a panel.
A mythological panel picture that is surrounded by a frame.
So just to make absolutely sure that the viewer understands what they are
looking at.
Here is a panel picture that hangs on a flat wall,
not a window into something that lies beyond but uh,
we see in the central zone the reintroduction of architecture,
substantial architecture where you can really make out the columns and the
pediments but not full buildings,
fragments of buildings,
fragments of buildings that are represented in very illogical space.
As you can see here,
again,
substantial elements like this with the supporting the columns supporting uh,
the lintel with the coffered ceiling represented in perspective.
So all of that brought back.
Uh,
but again these are not full buildings as we would see in the second style,
but these fragments in a logical space and a detail again of the same that I
just described and it's interesting to compare it to some details from second
style Roman wall painting.
Think a funniest Sydney store,
the Metropolitan Museum cubicles where you can actually,
and these are,
these are,
you can actually,
you really have a sense of,
of what this building was,
is a doorway that leads in.
And then there are a series of tears and there's a balcony in everything.
Everything connects to one another.
But here we see something quite different where we see not a whole building or
parts of a building together,
but rather these individual pieces that are depicted as I mentioned in a very
illogical way,
the,
the glory of Fourth Style Roman Wall painting I'm in depends on your taste
because it's very gaudy as well.
But one could say that the greatest,
uh,
preserved or the most interesting,
let's put it that way.
The most interesting preserved,
uh,
fourth style wall is also in the house of the Betty.
It is in the [inaudible] room of the house of the Betty.
We believe at dates to 70 to 79.
It is our,
you know,
an example of full blown fourth style at its most incredible.
And you know,
it's almost as if this artists wanted to be remembered for posterity.
We don't know his name unfortunately,
but remembered for posterity as the person who created the textbook example of
fourth style Roman wall painting.
And what's fascinating about it is what he has done is he has mixed together all
of the earlier styles.
First,
second,
third,
fourth first.
We see the Sokal down here is decker.
It's all done in paint,
but it is painted to represent marble or to imitate marble incrustation just as
we saw in the first style.
So the marble encrustation of the first style used for the Soco,
but again in paint,
not in relief.
The second tier we see the substantial columns supporting uh,
lintels and,
and tablatures with uh,
with um,
uh,
coffered ceilings represented in depth.
That's a second style element.
Third style,
these panels red with a mythological paintings in the center,
uh,
with frames and overhear a white panel with floral decoration and floating
mythological figures.
Those are elements of the third style and the fourth style reintroduction of
architecture in the central zone.
Fragments of architecture,
not full buildings,
fragments of architecture depicted in illogical space.
Uh,
and then in the upper most tier,
uh,
these architect,
these architectural cages with people with all kinds of strange figures,
animals,
divinities,
uh,
personifications and the like.
So all of those four styles brought together in one place.
Here's another view,
one that perhaps gives you an even better sense not of everything I've
described,
but of the overall appearance of this room as one walks into,
it's actually a very small room,
but it gives you the sense of grandiosity.
And this is interesting too because you see in this case the artist has kind of
matched up,
uh,
the,
I mean he's,
he's represented two very similar fragments.
One on either side.
That in a sense as you stare at it gives you the sense,
or at least it gives me the sense that perhaps maybe there is something that
continues behind the wall or behind the central mythological panel picture that
you see here.
But this is quintessential,
quintessential fourth style Roman wall painting.
I think I had,
I meant to show you also one fruit more detail here
where you can see again here,
you can see one of those,
uh,
one of these,
elements with the fragments of architecture and a logical space in detail.
And you can see even he been here too.
There are strange things going on.
We see masks reintroduced in the fourth style.
Uh,
we see in this case a mat.
That mask is supported by a panel picture that represents a,
a curved staff,
an animal,
uh,
some,
some baskets on top of the table.
I mean it's,
you try to interpret exactly what all this meant,
but it's interesting how much detail is put into these,
even though each of these individual items are difficult to see you 10,
when you walk into a room like this,
you tend to look at the whole and not at the individual details and yet the
artist's patrons and so on had paid a great deal of tension of attention to that
detail.
I want to show you lastly and thought we could talk about this for a couple few
minutes ourselves together.
Uh,
I one last fourth style or part of a fourth style Roman wall painting.
It is a fragmentary wall that we attribute to the fourth style,
uh,
that came from Herculaneum and dates also to this latest phase,
some time to 70 to 79.
Uh,
and it's quite interesting in view,
not only of what we've discussed today,
but in everything we've talked about,
uh,
with regard to the four styles of Roman will painting in the last,
you know,
week or so.
Uh,
I,
um,
you know,
what part of the wall you think this came from.
Uh,
and what you find interesting about at visa vi our general discussion of Roman
wall painting.
Someone liked to volunteer to,
to begin.
Yup.
We get a notice that looks like,
yes,
yes.
Yeah.
We've been debating this whole question of the black curtains and there's a post
now online and I hope that you'll all add to that as we continue that
conversation.
Uh,
this one,
in this particular case,
it seems in controvertible that what is represented here is a curtain.
There's no question that's a curtain.
It's hanging up there.
Uh,
so we get the sense that it is that it has been raised on what is a kind of a
stage set that lies behind.
So great point.
What else strikes you about this?
Yup.
Yes.
Based on the perspective that's used here,
based on the fact that there's a white background,
uh,
which isn't always the case in four style painting,
but it tends to be the case for most of it.
One could speculate that this is either one of those elements that has been
reintroduced in the main zone on either side of the central panel or what else
might it be?
Yeah,
right.
The illogical,
the,
the park part of a building in illogical specific,
it might be in the central zone as one of those side wings,
but it might also be way up in the top as one of the architectural cages,
uh,
that we see in the upper most part.
That's also possible.
Uh,
so what is being depicted here?
Okay.
Obviously a stage set of some sort.
How would you describe this architecture in the foreground?
You all know to state the obvious,
sorry,
it looks like Second Wendy wise.
It looks like second style because
projecting that it's substantial,
it's projected
good.
We have substantial architectural elements.
It's clear that these are our real columns with real capitals at the top that
those capitals project into our space.
The artist has made an effort to depict a recession into space as well cause you
can see the way in which these peers are angled.
For example,
back to give one the sense,
uh,
that we are looking at something depicted in space.
You can see the coffered ceiling up here or the projecting and tablet.
There's the mask,
which is an another reference to things the attrical.
But is there one point perspective here or is there any attempt to depict one
point perspective or is it some other kind of perspective and if so,
what kind of perspective,
what kind of perspective?
No one knows.
Yeah,
no what,
Yup.
Yeah.
But,
but it's more like
atmospheric perspective.
No disagree atmospheric perspective.
Uh,
so that again,
what's in the foreground is,
uh,
the outlines are from what's in the background is very,
very fuzzy and gets fuzzier and fuzzier.
Let me show you a detail of this.
If you blow it up,
you can see,
I mean,
try to count,
I don't know if you're counting tall,
if you try to count the zones of space here,
you'd go berserk.
Uh,
I mean,
clearly they are trying to conjure up space,
uh,
something that perhaps receipts,
but it seems to be done by means of atmospheric perspective.
What were wild,
where the objects in the foreground are represented with the firmest outlines
and those in the background with the fuzziest outlines.
As you can see here,
if you blow it up,
you can see that the details are incredible.
I mean,
you can see the decoration and the freezes.
You can see some of the figural,
a decoration,
the capitals and so on and so forth.
Uh,
but it is lost in this,
it is lost in,
in something of a haze as you can see here.
So it's,
it's a very good example of fourth style Roman wall painting.
It is some,
as it has been suggested,
it is a piece of the wallet.
Could be one of the wings.
It could be in the upper most zone.
It certainly makes reference to things.
The attrical.
It's certainly conjures up in some ways second style,
but it is,
it is clearly.
Um,
it is clearly an example of,
of fourth and again I'm glad that the Si,
the issue of the curtains was raised because I think that's a particularly
interesting one and because here we can really see a full bodied curtain.
I think it will help to add to the speculation that is already going on in the
online forum and about which I hope we can continue to engage in the days ahead.
We will have one last lecture on Roman painting on Thursday,
uh,
in which is entitled Special Subjects.
And I'm going to deal there with everything I haven't dealt with in the four
styles.
And then we are going to get back fully to architecture.
We'll go to Rome and we'll begin to look at the architecture under the emperors
Augustus and so on.
Thanks.